a New Yorker [__] fight
you as a New Yorker she'll [__] fight
me that is I now reconsidering raising
my daughter in New York City cuz if this
is what if this is what comes of it I am
a rapper I do freestyle rap that's rap
that you make up it's improvised on your
suggestions you the audience get to pick
what the rap is about you're all going
to think of a word or topic or phrase
that you'd like a rap about but there's
some there's some guidelines okay wait
for the GU okay okay we will have to
accept that okay um rules nothing too
British it just comes up a lot people
love shouting Megan and Harry you can do
better than that number two aside from
pastrami no more food or animals because
that's the most common thing our brains
think of and nothing too obvious by
which I mean anything I've said so far
and have fun with your suggestion be
creative the best example of this is a
German man who said a day in the life of
an Aztec high
priest do your rap about that English
man thank you so let's uh so we'll get
five suggestions so far we have pastrami
from two separate people that's
lovely okay whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa you just put both hands in the
air like this this isn't a [__]
Tiesto concert
what okay so okay we've got suggestion
number two from the ladies here what do
you want to wrap about a ginger that
wants to be a day Walker a ginger that
wants to be a day
Walker because they can't go outside and
I get it that's
yeah they think that's the best
suggestion that's ever been given and I
am not about to dissuade them of that
fact okay a day walking Ginger let's get
another one from this
side no no I'm taking that one don't
worry I'm just getting we we take five
total as a New Yorker she'll [__]
fight me that is I now reconsidering
raising my daughter in New York City cuz
if this is what if this is what comes of
it terrifying okay no I just wanted a
second one from this side as well who
said Blink 182 what was your favorite
Blink 182
song All the Small Things don't start a
sing along okay pami a Ginger Day Walker
Blink 182 All the Small Things okay and
what would you say we what you got a
hand up
there Meg Ryan in romantic comedies very
fitting very fitting yeah yeah that's
the sign is it um what are the other
what's another one she's been
[Music]
in You've Got Mail oh yeah yeah that was
a shot in bars and Noble on Broadway
yesly two people knew that fact you were
one and so was I and there was look at
that we should look we should have a
dinner under that sign see what happens
who knows apologies to any okay yeah
you're yeah you're holding her close I
will [__] fight
you let's get one final suggestion from
from this side who's yeah you got a hand
up there Scooby-Doo Onre Scooby do on
crack thank
you I knew we'd get there eventually
well this is what you've selected this
is what you've chosen pastrami a Ginger
Day Walker Meg Ryan in romantic comedies
Scooby-Doo on crack and um your one was
the All the Small Things by bling one it
too okay if you don't like the rap you
chose what the rap was about so it's
your fault Ethan do me a favor drop that
beat holy [__] yeah down a little bit
mate [__] late we don't want to get
noise complaints well this is a
freestyle as I said that's a Rap Made Up
On The Spot based on your suggestions do
not worry it will not be as [__] as
you're expecting it to be I love that
one woman in this room is feeling this
she's like
[Music]
yeah I see the ladies feeling it go
crazy for you back in the day they light
Blink 182 they're so amazing you know
the night real starter you see Travis
Barker Tom with the laughter dong and
then the other guy never know his name
but he's there playing bass what a damn
shame that they're old yes it's strange
they're like can you remind me what's My
Age Again but the one you want to ring a
ling yeah like I remember all of the
small things I'm hoing tiny little
trinkets they're in my box I listen to
Blink quite a lot I I got yo let me move
on I be trying I be sighing crying with
laughter when I'm seeing mag Ryan she be
over there feeling real P know it from
the movie When Harry Met Sally ad I've
never seen it I don't know the plot he
was like that's a nice pastrami you've
got an old lady in the corner she was
grabbing she's like oh I'll have what
she's having that's a vibrator love eggs
I love that you waving the scarf on your
head I caught this do you think I was
going to drop it I'll put it on the
thing it won't fit in my pocket but it's
nice good for a laugh never fail let me
talk about yeah you've got mail I'm over
there with the bookstore who to thank I
see Meg Ryan and Tom Hanks that's my guy
you are rapping along when you're coming
over here never getting it wrong we
charm these I make sure I cook it for
the hours the pastra me got special
powers is what I need I eating all of
the beef I top it with the mustard and
maybe with cheese if we using the Reuben
that's what we need a risk with the
brisket trying to succeed we got some
other stuff you know it's what we going
to do my drunk lady is like I'll fight
you I'm coming for you yeah run away jay
walk here in New York City but I'm
walking in the day time never going
wrong got the slightly brown hair or
it's tinged with the blonde but if it
was lingering more with an orange Hue
the drunk American girl she's like I'll
follow you what you even doing you weird
little pest in the daytime you need SPF
that's the sunscreen otherwise you burn
the ginger spies yes and he really
learns he's like oh I might burn badly
the name of the ginger Shaggy there in
the mystery machine with VMA he's there
with his big dog he wants to tell you oh
zo scoop will solve the mystery
Scooby-Doo's over there he's pissed to
be he's like uh I can't do that why
scoop cuz I'm addicted to crack that's
all that he needs take it front to back
he eats crack like it's a Scooby snack
and now Scooby's homeless he's out of
the crew he'd be there replaced by
Scrappy Doo cuz Scrappy do even though
he's an annoying pest he doesn't take
crack although he does take meth there
you go what's the solution to the
problem who really knows that's the
thing wave your salamis if you got
[Applause]
[Music]
them